السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته انا خالد
الجميلي اثبت نفسك اثبت حضورك اثبت فكرتك
شروط اساسيه للاستمرار في مغامرات الموسم
الثالث من برنامج نجوم العلوم اذا هذه
الخطوط العريضه لامسيه الليله خطوط راح
تسهر عليها لجنه تحكيم لا ترحم ولا تقبل
الا بالاثبات العلمي القاطع في هالليله 16
مشروع لن يتبقى منها الا عشره مشاريع فقط
كما سيغرد السته الباقون طائرين بعيدا
خارج المنافسه
[موسيقى]
مبدع عربي متفوق لمع في كل المحافل
الدوليه وحمل اسم العرب عاليا بافكاره
وابحاثه وانجازاته التي حازت على اعتراف
عالمي عبقري تابع المشتركين في الموسم
الثاني من نجوم العلوم مواكبه خطواتهم نحو
المعرفه اهو اليوم يعود ليكمل رسالته
الولد الله يرحمه كان يقول من يعلم فعليه
ان يعلم الناس والا فلا نفع في علمه انا
فاروق الباز جيولوجي اصلا من مصر خدت
الدكتوراه من جامعه مزوري في امريكا
وعملت في مشاريع لدراسه القمر
اسعدني في الحقيقه انني اتعامل مع الشباب
العربي اللي بيحاول انه ينتج اشياء جديده
نجوم العلوم هو ده المشروع ليؤهل الابداع
للشباب ويقول لهم ايوه كده يا شباب عرب
حاجه اللي بتعمله ممتازه وهنشجعكم وان
العامكم وسيروا الى الامام لان انتوا اللي
هتصلحوا العالم العربي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
دكتور رافقت المشتركين في الموسم الثاني
وكبت يعني خطواتهم ايش اللي تنتظره اليوم
من المبدعين اللي عندنا اليوم في حقيقه
الامر انا بس يكون واحد منهم وصل الى
المرحله اللي هو فيها دلوقتي دي تعني
احترامي لهم جميعا واحترامي لكل فرد لانه
انتم
بتمثله
المستقبل الامه العربيه وانا في نظري اي
واحد منكم كان جميعا واحد واحد وصل الى
احد في المعرفه يشرفنا جميعا شكرا جزيلا
لك
مؤسسه قطر للتربيه والعلوم وتنميه المجتمع
راعيه وصاحبه مبادره هذا البرنامج تضم عدد
كبير من الجامعات العالميه العريقه في كل
محطه من رحلتنا سيكون ضمن لجنه التحكيم
احد المبدعين والباحثين من هذه الجامعات
في امسيه الليله سيرافقنا الباحث الدكتور
اياد مسعد من جامعه تكساس في قطر مبدع
يعرف طموح الشباب وينصت الى احلامهم
[موسيقى]
دكتور اياد مسعد العميد المساعد للابحاث
والدراسات العليا في جامعه تكس في قطر
بروفيسور في الهندسه المدنيه والهندسه
الميكانيكيه في الجامعه الام في
فرع الجامعه في قطر
برنامج نجوم العلوم فكره مبدعه بحد ذاتها
لانه بتقدم للشباب مبدا انك انت ممكن ان
تكون نجم من خلال العلوم
اتوقع حماس اكثر بتوقع انه هذه المجموعه
اكيد استفادوا من تجربتي المجموعه السابقه
نصيحتي للمشتركين بهذا السيزون انهم
يركزوا اكثر شي على نقطه الابداع في
المشروع ما يدخلوا في التفاصيل اللي حول
النقطه وحيوصلوا حتى لو ما وصلوا
بالبرنامج انا متاكد المجموعه اللي شاركت
السنه الماضيه حتلاقي فرصه حتلاقي فرصه
يمكن دراسات عليا تلاقي فرصها بشغل لانه
هاي النفسيه وهاي القدره على اثبات الذات
حتلاقي حطها
يا هلا وسهلا فيك في برنامج هجوم العلوم
شكرا دكتور اياد حضرتك جامعي وخلع احتكاك
اكيد بالطلاب في الجامعات هل يعني لاحظت
حماس الشباب وادراكهم لاهميه البحث
وتحمستم ايضا للابداع يعني انا بقول انه
الجيل الحالي
افكار
وايمان بالنفس اكثر من الاجيال السابقه
احنا متفاجئ دائما بقدراتهم وقدرتهم على
الابداع حتى في الكلاسيز يعني دار اميزنج
قدرته مع الابداع شكرا جزيلا لك
في اللجنه وفي البرنامج يعرفني جميع
المشاريع عرفيقانها خطوه خطوه حكيمان
عادلان لنرحب بالمهندس اللواء محمد
الكواري والدكتور فؤاد مراد عضوي لجنه
التحكيم الدائمين
الدكتور فؤاد مراد
رائد من رواد رحله نجوم العلوم منذ
البدايه كان حاضرا بخبرته وتمارسه العلمي
والمهني
وما زال حتى هذا الموسم من نجوم العلوم
خلال المواسم الثلاثه قيم الدكتور فؤاد
مراد المشاريع المشاركه منذ توافد
الاستمارات عبر الانترنت
اسلوب مميز مبروك وراي واضح صريح هذا
ممتاز وان كان قاسيا المبدا العلمي شخصيه
سيتذكرها حتما كل من حضر نجوم العلوم اما
الوجه الاخر للدكتور فؤاد مراد
انا المدير التنفيذي
للمركز الاقليمي لاستخدام التكنولوجيا من
اجل التنميل
من اهم المهام المناطه فينا هي دعم الشباب
في عمليه الابتكار العلمي وهذا الارتباط
الوفيق ما بين عملي بالامم المتحده
وببرنامج زوم العلوم كحكم
ببرنامج نجوم العلوم انا شخصيا بحس في
مسؤوليه كتير كبيره على كتافي لانه متابع
لهذا المشروع من اليوم الاول لنتاكد انه
يقدر يحمل بجداره اسم مؤسسه قطر للتعليم
في
العلوم مرحبا بك في برنامج النجوم العلوم
فلما طاقم البرنامج
ثاني العربيه
افضل المبتكرين العرب لهذا الموسم راح
نختار الافضل من الافضل ميزات
الذي يقدم لهم خبرته
بصله قوات الانبار ومعرفته التقنيه
والعلميه
وبالطبع رعايته الابويه والله هو صعب يرفض
لانه فيه فكره
اعمل كرئيس مركز عطل لتطويل الكفرات تابع
لشركه العالميه جن
رال الاوروبيه للفضاء والملاحه الجويه
مركز قطر لتطوير الكفاءات ورئيس المشروع
المشترك بين الشركه ومؤسسه اللحام
الفرنسيه
[تصفيق]
مرحبا فيك شكرا
في المراحل الاولى من التصفيات كنت صارم
شديد ولكن بقساوه الاب على ابنائه هل راح
نشاهد اليوم امام المشتركين ايضا مثل هال
الصرامه والقساوه معهم
كل اذا كان في صرامه ابويه واذا في تشجيع
فهو تشجيع المعلم لتلميذه
دكتور فؤاد مراد يعطيك العافيه اهلا وسهلا
فيك دكتور فؤاد مراد انت عندك يعني خاصيه
متميزه شوي مثل القبضه الحديديه في القفاز
المخملي بالنسبه للمشتركين هل راح نشوف
اليوم القبضه الحديديه هذي امام المشتركين
بصرامه بقسوه يعني القبضه الحديديه هي
لمصلحه الشباب العربي لانه بالعلم
وبالانتاج ما في مسيرات وانا مصر انه
ببرنامج نجوم العلوم يتطور من سنه لسنه
ومن سنه لسنه يصير القبضه الحديديه اكثر
جديه شكرا دكتور فؤاد مراد
اذا هؤلاء هم حراس مدينه العلوم وحملوا
مفاتيحها لهذه الليله هم وحدهم اصحاب
القرار والبرهان العلمي هو السبيل الوحيد
لينال اي مشروع رضاهم للبقاء في فضائل
البرنامج ولكن قراراتهم ليست ابدا عشوائيه
انما تخضع لمعايير دقيقه والنقاط ستتوزع
على شكل التالي خمسين نقطه لاثبات فعاليه
الفكره 30 نقطه لاثبات امكانيه تصنيع
المنتج وعشرون نقطه للاداء والحافز الشخصي
اجره التحكيم جاهزه لمهمتها الصعبه
والمبدعون راح يبداون بمواجهه اللجنه
للدفاع عن مشاريعهم فاصل قصير مشاهدينا
الاعزاء يمكنكم خلال زياره موقعنا
الالكتروني
بالنسبه للمشاركين انا متاكد انهم ما راح
يرتاحون قبل نهايه الامسيه وظهور النتائج
فاصل ونرجع
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
المنافسه العلميه تبدا الان المبدع الاول
يعمل بجد وجهد على مشروع ملصقات الاستشعار
التي تعمل باللمس لجنه التحكيم ستحاول ان
تلمس الان فعاليه فكره هيثم دسوقي من مصر
كيبقى الاستشعار شعرا على ورق نشوف
اعتقد من التكنولوجيا اصبحت حاجات كتير
حوالينا تاتش
ليه ما نتحكمش بسرعه ودرجه حراره المياه
بالطط
ليه ما نخليش هدومنا تاتش ساعدنا في
حياتنا اليوميه
ليه ما نقفلش النور ونفتحه بالتاتش
الاسئله دي حلها كلها عندي مشروع التاتش
ستيكر هيحاول كل حاجه حوالينها تاتش ويخلق
عالم خلف عالمنا يسهل علينا حياتنا
بدايه المبدا العلمي لمشروعك هيثم بحاجه
انه بهالمرحله هيك يكون عامل ماتريكس
اتخضيت انا بدي اطلع منها
اصلا
منطقه مش منطي بوزيشن سؤال انا هحتاج فيه
الابلكيشن بتاعي اني احط مثلا صباعي في
اكتر من خمس اماكن مع بعض ده احبطني لان
انا حسيت ان انا هاعيد الشغل تاني من
الاول وانا هاخد وقت اطول من المقرر ليا
الطاوله محطوط السيستم تبعك كبست برجر
بعرف اني كبست برجر كبست بيتزا بعرف اني
كبست بيتزا تمام
يعني ماشي تمام اوكي جدا
[موسيقى]
يربح صار التاتش
كتير محضر هو هلا جاهز يواجه لجنه الحكم
جاهز للانجينيرين قاطع شقفه حتى من
الانجينيرين واثبت الكونسبت تبعه والحمد
لله انا خلصت مشروعي بدري ودلوقتي انا
مرتاح وخليت الاستيكر يبقى وايرلس واعتقد
النقطه دي ان شاء الله هتكون في مصلحتي
قدام لجنه
[موسيقى]
او ملصقات استشعار تعمل باللمس الاستيكر
ده بيتلزق تحت اي سطح بيحوله من فوق تاتش
يعني لو لمست كده
ولمست كده مكان التاتش بان وعلى الشفاف
برضو
في شروط على المستخدم من ناحيه فياجو
حذائه يمكن موضوع الحذاء او كده انا مجرب
عامل تست على الموضوع بتاع الحساب ده
بالذات انك انت لو حتى لمست المشروع
برجليك وانت لابس الحذاء نفسه هيحس هيعمل
تاتش
تاكل الفكره ان موضوع الحذاء او كده لا لا
حتى لو عليك حتى لو كان عليك جراوند فغيرت
طريقه السنس نفسها اني احط فيه احط
فريكونسي سبيد سبيكتوم على كل على كل
ابليس واول ما تلمس التشارجس لجوه جسمك
بتاثر على الفريكونسي بتاع اللي انت حاطه
على البلاي فانا كده بعدت عن الموضوع
في قاعه الانتظار يقف عبد الله الرويشد
ليحصل على اشاره الانطلاق ومملكه التحكيم
فقط سنعرف ان كان سيتابع سيره ام انه
سيحصل على اشاره التوقف الحمراء لنتابع
كم مره حنا نسوق قطعنا اشارات حمراء من
دون ما ننتبه
وكم مره شفنا اشارات ما نعرف شنو معناته
وكم مره شفنا اشارات قديمه ومنتهيه
صلاحيتها
فكره اختراعي
درايفر قامت بحل جميع تلك المشاكل
وهي جعل جميع الارشادات المروريه على شاشه
داخل السياره
الخطوات اللي بدنا نعملها بثلاثه اسابيع
هذا الريدر بدنا نوصله على البي سي بقلب
السياره
بدك تشوف وين بدك تحط على الطريق على
القليله 3 تاكس
بدنا نختبر اذا فعلا السياره مرقت قريت
هوليد
[موسيقى]
زي ما انتم شايفين انا مستانس لانه
التجربه الاولى صحيح كانت فيها مشاكل لكن
تمت وبنجاح
كل ما تسرع شوي لارا عم يقنروا اقل واقل
وكل ما بعدنا عم ينقروا
المشاكل هذه راح نعالجها نحاول نعالجها
بالاسبوع الجايين
عم نجرب هلا يحل مشكله اذا عنده اشاره من
ميلتين من الطريق كل وحده لمايل من الطريق
بدو يعرف اي وحده بدو ينقي المفروض تنحل
معه بكره بالنسبه للسرعه فيها شويه شغل
اكثر ماشي بسرعه شويه صغيره ما عم بياخده
فمشكله بيصير عنده بس لجنه الحكم متقرر
اذا الكرودك جاهز او لا
[موسيقى]
طبعا
اللوحات الارشاديه تظهر داخل شاشه في
السياره فمثلا لو كنا نسير وفي وقت ضباب
في اللوحات العاديه اللي تطلع في الشارع
ما نقدر نشوف اللوحات الارشاديه لكن مع
المشروع حقي راح تطلع اللوحات الارشاديه
داخل السياره على الشاشه واللي عن النقاط
اللي حددت لك في البروفف كونسبت
الجهاز بالكمبيوتر ربط الجهاز والكمبيوتر
برمج الجهاز برمجه الجهاز بحيث انه يقرا
برمج ثلاث طاقات بدل ما برمج ثلاثه برمجه
سته واخر شيء تسوي تست للجهاز سويت كل
المراحل هذا انت عندك شي ضد الستلايت
عندك عندك مشكله ما
وليش
ما اعتقد راح
يفكر فيها انت بتكره جي بي اس مثلا
ليش عندي شيء ضده لانه كتير بتتغير معك
اذا بنعتمد واليوم اغلبيه السيارات فيها
ممكن ليش لا لكن اللي انا قاعد استخدم
الحين من دون جي بي اس ممكن بعدين هل هو
موقف شخصي يعني
ممكن بعدين في المستقبل ممكن نستخدم
نحط جي بي اس ممكن نستخدمه
[تصفيق]
داني عيد لم تكن مسيرته كلها اعياد
الصعوبات واجهتها من كل حد وصوب اتخطى
داني اعيد كل الصعوبات العلميه وهل توصل
الى نتيجه ترضي لجنه التحكيم تقرير
فمواجهه فمصير
[موسيقى]
انا كثير بحب التكنولوجيا بكل هالتطور
اللي عم نشوفه حوالينا في احلى من انك
تلبس نظارات تخليك تعرف معلومات عن اشخاص
تلتقى فيهم ما بتعرفهم او يدق الموبايل
وتشوف بالنظرات ذاتهن مين عم يتصل فيك
[تصفيق]
هيدي
هيلتي اختراعي النظارات ذكيه لتشخيص
الواقع راح تعمل ثوره بالعالم بمجال
الالكترونيكس
بثلاث اسابيع كيف بدك تزيد من كاميرا على
شاشه اللي هي قدامك وهي شفافه وموصولين
على الكمبيوتر
بعد المراد بلشتان يشتغل على تبعه تعامل
كل البوينت المطلوبين منه
يحط شاشه دغري قدام العيون تيقدر يحط
المعلومات كان عندي بس هذه المشكله لانه
الانسان ما راح يركز العين تاني وشاشه
وعلى العالم اللي عم يشعر
قرر تاني هلا بحط شاشه مع اثنين لانس
يحطوا فوق في الكاميرا هون
بدي انفرميشن بنزله كاميرا
هلا هايدي مشكله لانه هذا موجود بالسوق
قرر داني يحط شاشه عين وحده عين تقشع
المعلومات اللي بده يحطها
كانه الواحد قاعد بالسينما حيكون في مشكله
بالفوكس عندك لانه الواحد بيكون مركز يطلع
لبعيد لانه القزازه كتير قريبه على العين
30 ثانيه بكون ضخمه وراسنا عم بوجعنا
وبعد كل المشاكل اللي واجهتها هلا كتير
مبسوط لانه اخيرا لقيت الحل مايك بس
[موسيقى]
اليوم وصلنا لهدفنا لهالمرحله
اللي هي نشوف المعلومات اللي على الشاشه
الشفافه بوضوح ونشوف الحيه بنفس الوقت
واكيد هيدا
وتفتح عين هيدا مانو علم ما منسكر
لانه هيدي لو فيني شوف فيها الواقع كنت
عملت البسها البسها
اقنعني ان هاي فاشله
طيب
البث الاعلامي عبر الواي فاي لم يواجه
صعوبات كثيره خلال المرحله الماضيه ماجد
الابابيدي بدا مرتاحا على وضعه لكن هل
ستقتنع لجنه التحكيم ام انها سترسل له
بيانات الخروج من المنافسه عبر وسيله اخرى
اكثر فعاليه من مشروعه راح نشوف
منكم
انا لقيت الحل بوفر عليكم هاي النظره
نحن مثل ما بنعرف كلياتنا بنستخدم شبكات
عن طريق اللابتوب او السمارت فون انا قدرت
استفيد من جهاز هاردوير صار فيكم عن طريقه
تحملوا ومستندات الموجوده فيه بسرعه كتير
قياسيه اتصل ل600
بمرحله البروفوف كونسبت كان لي خطوات لازم
اعملها انه الجوري فينا تفتح وتشوف الداتا
عم تطلع ما في تاخير ابدا ما في شيء حتى
يستفيدوا من السرعه اللي عم تقدمها الخطوه
الاولى هي اجابه هاردوير فيه فلاش ميموري
بحيث نقدر نخزن اكبر عدد من المعطيات
بقلبها ثاني شيء
كان لازم اعمل بحيث يكون سهل التعامل معها
اخر شيء اعمل تيستينج لهذا السيناريو
المشاكل واجهتني كان بدي اياه عالاشاره
بقلب اللاب لانه باللاب كان في اكثر من 15
عم تشتغل على نفس الاشاره عم تقطش اضطرينا
نعمل تست بره لحتى نشوف انه الاشاره ما
بتضيع ابدا
هذه اللي قلنا هاي الانترنت وعندي الصراع
اكثر بكثير من الانترنت وصلت لاونت 502
ميج بالسنه انا راضي كثير على النتائج
اللي حققتها بمرحله بس اكيد في عندي كثير
رح تواجهني بباقي المراحل ان شاء الله اذا
تاهلت
[موسيقى]
انا اختراعي هو كيفيه نقل اكبر كميه
معلومات بسرعه كتير هائله عن طريق استخدام
شبكات اللاسلكيه مثلا في داتا بتنزل لمن
كنت تجرب الفايل كم كان بياخذ وقت ومع
السكربت اللي انت عملته كم اخذ وقت تماما
اللي عملناها
فايل حجمه تقريبا 8 ميجا عن طريق اليوتيوب
اخد تقريبا
اربع دقايق و15 سنه عن طريق الشبكه اللي
انا عملتها اخذت تقريبا لا يتجاوز اربعين
سنه
تخزنت الفيديو او الفيلم اللي كنا بنحضره
على الجهاز تمام
هون الفكره انه نحن استفدنا من من
شو معناه هائله يعني
قياسيه كمان تمام عنوان عريض
بسرعه السرعه جيده السرعه تتناسب يعني اذا
في عندي يوتيوب
كيف بتقارن حالك لسرعه البرودمان عفوا كيف
بتقارن الابلكيشن تبعك لبرود باند بصراحه
هذا هذا الشيء اللي انا طامح له انا كيف
فيني اخلق ياخد كميه داتا كتير كبيره وبضل
حجمه كثير صغير ونقل المعلومات تبعي كتير
كبير
كمان يعني كل موضوعك ما عم بستعمل الا
هائله قياسيه واكثر ولا شو
رياضه الجوده تعرف الضربه القاضيه باسم
ايفون وائل السعدي سيحاول ان يحقق النقطه
الكامله مع ابتكار مساعد مدرب الفنون
القتاليه الذكي كي لا تخرجه لجنه التحكيم
معاني التتامى بضربه ايبون من حركه
تاشيوازا انتبهوا
[موسيقى]
مع انها رياضه مهمه جدا تعتمد على القوه
بنسبه 30% وعلى تقنيه الحركه وهندسه
التحركات بالنسبه السبعين بالمئه
[موسيقى]
ابرز عده مشاكل من هذه المشاكل اولا مشكله
الدوران
المشكله الاخرى هي مشكله التوازن
فكان ذلك الاختراع هو مساعد مدرب الفنون
القتاليه الذي يساعد المدرب بشكل كبير على
تنميه اداء اللاعبين ومراقبتهم بدك تزيد
حساسات على البدله اذا ما ترجمتم
لمعلومات مفيده للتبريد ما استفدنا لانه
ما عنا منتج كانت هذه المتحسسات كبيره
بصراحه الحمد لله تم اختصارها متخصصات
صغيره
وفعاله في نفس الوقت في تلك الاثناء كنت
انا اعمل على برنامج المحاكاه وبرنامج
التلقي المعلومات من البدله
واحد التقاطع السنسر الثاني اللي هو الوسط
اوكي واستنسر الثالث اللي هو ضربه السابق
هذا البايبل يصور لك الضربه الاولى الضربه
الثانيه الضربه الثالثه ما دامهن بالوان
طبيعيه يعني ماكو اي خطا اذا صار لون احمر
يعني عنده خطا بهذا المكان يبين لك لون
احمر هذا المكان مكان الحركه الخطا
في
الصحيح يعني كسحبه كدخله والسرعه العام
لوائل
هو يعطيك السرعه
هذا في مشكله في السرعه واذا في مشكله في
التكنيك
[موسيقى]
اختبر هذا الجهاز على اكثر رياضات الفنون
القتاليه تعقيدا وهي رياضه الجودو المعقده
الهندسه هل انت تجيد الفنون القتاليه لانه
هذا سيحدد
كيف نتعامل معك يعني
لا نجيد
في مثل هذه المواضع يعني يجب الحذر عند
التعامل مع هكذا شخص
احسنت يا بني
اتفضل بصراحه نحن الان احوج ما يكون الى
الفنون القتاليه هي ليست لاشاعه الشغب
واشاعه هكذا اشياء وانما
النفس الكريمه مع النفس الشجاعه في الفنون
القتاليه الكلاميه زي بتاعه الرؤساء الدول
العربيه
بصراحه يعني كنت على بساط التدريب مده
ثلاثه اشهر يعني اسقط ارضا دائما يعني
كلما ادخل نزال اكون خاسرا الفضل لله
بعد هذا الجهاز ان شاء الله نفس الوضع لا
ان شاء الله انتم تحبون اذا تحبون اكو اني
زعلان يعني انا ممنون
تسمعني
سبحان الله يعني اذا اشوفكم واحد هو اصلا
مرتبط ويشوفكم يعني وش يصير
عندي اسئله لالك سؤالين
نحن وقت اللي تعاونا وشفناك وتاهلت معنا
لهالمرحله كان العنوان انه هيدي البدله
الذكيه كلمه ذكيه البدله الذكيه وهي
اللي بدها تساعد الانسان يتدرب
هلا صرنا نقول اعطاء المدرب مساعده انا
اذا عندي مدرب هيدي البدله يعني
انا بدي يكون في شخصين عم يتدربوا مع
بعضهم وما في مدرب لهم
والبدله تكون عم تساعدهم كلمه البدله
الذكيه مش معناتها بدله عندها حساسات
الذكيه يعني في في ذكاء مثل ما انت الحمد
لله
معناتها في خبره تراكميه وبتعطينا معلومات
بناء على
نحطه بناء على معرفه مخزنه بالبرنامج أنا
اكيد كل التوفيق
اعضاء لجنه التحكيم يقيمون اداء كل من
هيثم عبد الله داني ماجد
بعضهم قد يكون في دائره الخطر
من دائره الخطر الدائره الساخنه دعونا
نخرج الى دائره الاستراحه القصيره وانتم
اعزائي المشاهدين لا تخرجوا من الغرفه
لاننا عائدون مع مزيد من الاثار العلميه
والمزيد عن برنامجنا في الموقع الالكتروني
واكيد على جروبنا في الفيسبوك انتظرونا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا بكم مجددا في الموسم الثالث من
نجوم العلوم خلال الايام الماضيه كان محمد
الشعري التونسي طوال الوقت واثقا من نفسه
عمل بجهد على مشروعه املا بتحقيق نتيجه
ايجابيه تشحن طموحها بمزيد من الطاقه
خلونا نشوف كيف كانت رحله محمد الشعري من
تونس
الروبوتات التي تقوم بعمليه مراقبه انابيب
النفط تتعرض الى مشكل نفاذ البطاريه ما هو
ما يجرنا الى قطع انبوب النفط من اجل شحن
هذه البطاريه واعادتها داخل انبوب مره
ثانيه وهو ما يكلفنا خساره ماديه جسيمه
جدا هذا بالاضافه الى خساره الوقت اثناء
عمليه انجاز المشروع
انا اخترعت جهاز يتمثل في ارسال الطاقه
الكهرومغناطيسيه داخل انبوب النفط وهو ما
يمكننا من شحن بطاريات هذا الروبوت
لاسلكيا بهالمرحله فقط بدنا نبرهن انه وصل
الطاقه
بعدين الاختبارات انابيب نفط حقيقيه من
اجل اثبات الفكره
كذلك استعملنا الميكرويف الموجود في
المنزل وقمنا بقطعه لاخذ جهاز الذي يمكن
من ارسال الطاقه اقل الكهرباء مغناطيسيه
داخل انبوب النفط
من اجل اختبار انتقال الطاقه الميكرويف
لاسلكيا قمنا بوضع ضوء 21 وات على بعد ست
امتار و12 متر وكان النتيجه ايجابيه هيدا
جعل محمد زياد يكون فرحان ومتحفز انه يكفي
معنا
بالاضافه لهذا الشيء قمنا باخذ الكارنت
والفولتج على هذا الضوء والنتائج كتير
مطمئنه
[موسيقى]
تتمثل جهازي في ارسال الطاقه الكهربائيه
لاسلكيا لشحن بطاريه الروبوت اثناء عمليه
المراقبه
بيبقى موجود في الانبوبه عندما في الوقت
اللي انتم عايزين تشوفوا فيه
مش في اثناء الضخ النفس في الاوقات اللي
انت عايز تشوف فيها كذا وهو الشريكه
الشركه التي تريد مراقبه انابيبها ترسل
بالشركه حول العالم انترناشونال يعني تطلب
منها الطلب يعني يضبط فيه الوقت يعني بتاع
الاسبرج يدخل الروبوت دخل به بالنفط من
اجل المراقبه وهذا الانبوب اللي طوله
كيلومتر اذا ما كان بخط مستقيم
انظر جيدا استاذي الكريم
خلي بالك يا راجل خلي بالك خد بالك خد
بالك
[ضحك]
يعني
ممكن في المرحله القادمه
في الموسم الثالث لكنها مثال للمراه
العربيه الطموحة
الدقيقه في عملها مثابره نشيطه باحثه كيف
لا ومشروعها طبي بامتياز لنرى ماذا فعلت
الاردنيه سيرين الشرايري في الايام
الماضيه
مبدا السكري بزودوا حالهم بالانسولين عن
طريق الابر
طبعا هاي الابر بتوجع وبتسبب لهم حساسيه
وكثير ناس صغار وكبار عندهم فوبيا من
الابر
مريض السكري رح اسهل لك حياتك واغنيك عن
استخدام الابر لاني اخترعت جهاز الترا
سانت سيستم بوصل لك الانسولين لبشرتك بدون
ابر
بدك تبرني من خلال استخدام جلدي بدون اي
جهاز هل قد مرق انسولين بخلال ساعه هذا هو
المطلوب فقط بهالمرحله
بعد ما عملت شويه ريسيرشز عن الموضوع
سوينا ديزاين
حتى اتاكد انها بتوصل للجهه الثانيه
والحمد لله زبطت مع المي المرحله اللي
بعدي
ها راح أني مرات
بدون المشكله الاساسيه اللي واجهتني في
قطر البروتوكول بيمنع انه نعمل تجارب على
الحيوانات فعشان هيك قررنا نسويها بالاردن
انا زعلانه ومعصبه ما رح احضر اول
اكسبيريمان
راح اضلني متوتره لبين ما يخلصوها
كان كتير صعب وقدرني اصيح واحكي اسوي هيك
اعمله هيك شو
يعني كثير طولت وتعامل هيك دغري بتخلص
الدروب يعني
لازم اشوف قديش الدوس اللي راح اعطيه
للراد
[موسيقى]
اختراعي هو جهاز لتوصيل للانسولين لمريض
السكري عن طريق الالترا ساوند بدون ابر
كميه الانسولين اللي بتعمليها
في هذه التجربه ثري يونت
هلا كل 100
دي ممكن تاثر على اي حاجه تانيه
ممكن نسمعيها او
هي فوق نطاق السمعه الانسان في اي احتمال
الذبذبات الصوسيه دي تؤثر على الجلد ما في
احتمال يعني كثير بسيط احتمال انه تؤثر
عليها لانه احنا اصلا في كل مكان في
حوالينا في فريكونس واعلى من هيك
معدده هي مركزه على منطقه معينه بس مش
لطول العمر يعني انت عم تستخدم الجهاز
لفتره معينه في اليوم
المريض السكر بياخذ الابره خلال يعني اقل
من دقيقه يكون عطل الانسولين اللي يحتاجه
هذه كم مفروض يقعد يعني الوقت تقريبا 30
دقيقه يكون عليك حتى يعطيك يعني نفس الرجل
تبعي طبعا احنا هون عم عم نستغني عن الوجع
اللي عم ياخدوا المريض في سبيل انه شوي
انه يقعد ويحطوا على حاله واكيد الديفاي
زي ما انتم شايفين كتير صغيره يعني ممكن
نستخدمه كابورتابل ديفايس فما راح يعوق
المريض كثير في الحركه
نواف سعيد ابتكر جهاز لاسلكي لتحديد
المواقع هو عمل جاهد ليحقق موقع متقدم بين
رفاقه هاي جميع المشتركين لكن لجنه
التحكيم موحدها راح تحدد موقع نواف في
المنافسه خلونا نشوف
[موسيقى]
حلوه جات مشكله في ايجاد طبيب او ممرضه
وانت في المستشفى هل واجهت صعوبه وانت في
المجمع على العثور على احد افراد العائله
او الاصدقاء ان كانت اجابتك نعم انا لقيت
الحل
تخيلوا مثلا انكم ساكنين في احد الفنادق
وكنتم محتاجين شغله ولا صار عطل في احد
الاجهزه الكهربائيه
[موسيقى]
بقسم السياره لما يحصل على برد ويرسل لكم
باخذ
انا اخترعت اختراع يحلها المشكله اختراع
جهاز بامكانه تحديد الاشخاص داخل المباني
والاتصال فيهم بدون استخدام فبالتالي
الفندق بيستخدمها للجهاز عشان يحدد اقرب
شخص لغرفتك وارساله لحل مشكلتكم
البرمجه للهاتف الجوال اللي هي موجوده
بغرفه المراقبه وبدنا نعمل تراكينج للحامل
هذا الهاتف الجوال بقلبها المبنى في
البدايه بدات استخدم المجرن كيب عشان احسب
المسافات اللي في الغرفه واخذ القراءات
بكل مقطع قدرت احصل على معادله ممتازه
ممكن تحدد لي موقع الشخص بدقه عاليه
المشاكل كانت بسيطه النويس اللي يصدر من
الاجهزه مع اجهزه ثانيه طبعا الخبراء
قدروا يساعدوني
[موسيقى]
حصلت لي على طريقه معينه بامكاني الغي
هالاصوات وحدد الموقع بدقه عاليه جدا اكثر
من ما تصور
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته اختراعي
هو باختصار تحديد الموقع باستخدام الواي
فاي
طبعا ما نستخدم لا جي بي اس ولا لان في
مشاكل
اذا كانت للشرطه
بالنسبه حق الاستخدامات انا يمكن في
الجامعه كنت ابحث عن احد الاكاديميه وخذلك
وقت طويل تقريبا ثلث ساعه اني احاول احصله
وهذا الشيء ادى الى اني اختار وادى الى ان
المحاضره بكبرت تتعطل زين هاي النقطه
الاولى يمكنك
مجمع هاي بعد نقطه ثانيه
في دبي يتبسط منك جدا في العقيدي عشان
عشان المواقع وفين انور فين واحد في
الغرفه بتاعك
الشخص
اللي يحمل الجهاز ده لابد ان يكون موافق
على حمله موافق على حمله اولا لازم اي
تليفون بتعمل به كده
في رقم معين
من البدايه خلاص بيشتغل على طول معاه
قوه قراءه معينه انت متفاعل كتير يعني
اعضاء لجنه التحكيم يقيمون اداء محمد زياد
سيرين وانور المنافسه تشتد وسته من
المشتركين سيغادرون في ختام هذا الحفل
الدفعه الثالثه المبدعين تنتظر ايضا على
احر من الجمر واحنا بعد راح نتركها تنتظر
اكثر واكثر وراح نتوقف مع فاصل قصير لا
تنسوا مشاهده المزيد عن برنامجنا على
الموقع الالكتروني
او على مجموعتنا على موقع الفيسبوك فاصل
ونرجع
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مجددا اهلا وسهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام في
تصفيات الاثبات العلمي للفكره وبدايه
الدفعه الثالثه من المبدعين ستكون مع سعد
القحطاني من قطر وجهاز تدريب الخيول هل
سيقفز سعد فوق حجز اللجنه ام اننا سنقول
لكل جواد كبوه
الخيل نايم ولا تعبان طبعا لا
احسن صوره ممكن تشوف الحصان فيها وهو يركض
ويتحرك بحيويه ونشرت
[موسيقى]
الحصان نفس الانسان ممكن يصاب
جهازي يدرب ويؤهل ويساعد الخيل على تجاوز
الاصابه بطريقه مبتكره لا تؤثر على سلامه
المفاصل
طالبينه منك تصميم وتنفيذ
اليوم بدينا الشغل جينا على مربط الشقب
عشان نعمل بعض التجارب العمليه على بحيث
نقدر ناخذ مسار حركه ارجل الخيل طريقه
المشي هايده مشكله كتير كبيره
الحصان عم تفوت من جوا لبرا ما عم تمشي
المشكله بتصميم مش كبير شوي انصدم هاي
نجرب ونشوف من بعد ما اخذنا مسار اجر
الحصان اليوم رح نروح على الكمبيوتر
نستخرج هالمسار ونبلش بعمليه تصميم الجهاز
فكان مثل طالع
[موسيقى]
ه متر يعني
المشكله دكتورة بس لازم اسويها بسرعه بحيث
انه خيل يتاقلم على جهاز جديد يبي له فتره
هالجهاز اخيرا
هلا عن نسبه المبدا انه الحصان قادرين
نوقفوا على هالمشين وبتحرك مشاكل بجهاز
ساعتها اول شيء الحصان لازم يكون متاقلم
مع الجهاز ثاني شيء ممكن نحن نثبت اجر
الحصان على الفيدلز راح يفضل الحصان اكيد
قطعا واخر شيء غير انه الجهاز عالي رح
توصل على محل تقدر تعمل فيه لوكينج انا
صراحه انصدمت انا قبل قلت انه العمليه
الحين اقدر اقول 64
[موسيقى]
جهازي طبعا جهاز جديد تدريب الخيل باليه
جديده فكره يعني مبتكره طبعا يعتمد على
اربع دواسات ثبت عليها حوافر الخيل وتعمل
على
تدريب الخيل بمتابعه مسار حركه رجل الخيل
سعد متهيا لك انه كبير شوي ممكن نتغلب على
هالمشكله باكثر من طريقه
ممكن اذا اقتنعنا في مسار الحركه اللي
ياخذ الجهاز ننزل الجهاز في نفس الحفره
بحيث انه ما يكون طالع منها الا سطح
الجهاز بالنسبه للنوات اللي طلبناها منك
بهالمرحله كان في نقطه بتقول بدنا نشوف
الخيل ونشوفوا بس واقف على هالمكنه
وانا ما شفته يعني طلع على جسر حديد بس ما
قرب على الميكانيزم شو صار اللي صار انه
انا خفت على سلامه الحصان ففضلت اني احافظ
على سلامه الحصان من اني اثبت رجله ويصير
لا انا ما بغيت اثبت رجع من البدايه كان
في هل في مجال الحصان راح يقبلوا يحط
رجليه على هيدي الميكانيزم نمشي فيها كان
في امكانيه لكن فضلنا انه ما نخاطر
بسلامه الخيل عشان بس نثبت ارجل الخيل على
على الميكانيكيه شو هي النقطه اللي بدها
تخليني اخد
هالخطوه التاليه انه يكون عندي ثقه وحاول
تثبت رجل الخيل على هالمكنه ما عم نعرف
ليه ما حاولنا ما اقدر انا انا في مرحله
التطوير اجي ويكون عندي في الهيستوري او
في الريكورد انه والله الاخ يطور الجهاز
البحث الاخير ولا سبب اصابه عاهه حق الخيل
يعني افضل اني اوقف الاختبار واتخذ
اجراءات السلامه المناسبه اللي تضمن
لسلامه الخير من اني
خطوه كتير مسؤوله كنت عم تتصرف بالمسؤولية
بقول لك انا بعمل زي الخيل اللي عندك بروح
على الجيم بشوف المشيم بس ما بركب عليها
بس بشوفها
في مختبرات الامضه حمدي حشاد ايام طويله
يدرس يجرب يعمل يعاند يكرر يتحدى الاخفاق
لكن التحدي الحقيقي لحمدي سيبدا بعد قليل
امام لجنه التحكيم الموقره استخراج الوقود
من الطحالب هل سيثبت علميا
عند ارتفاع اسعار النفط بنسق جنون الى
ادخال العالم في ازمه اقتصاديه طاحنه
اخطر الا وهي التهاب اسعار المواد
الغذائيه
كان الوقود المستخرج من الطحالب من افضل
الوسائل البديله
[موسيقى]
من هنا جاءت فكره مشروع التي تتمثل في
استعمال تحالب مضره للبيئه
لاستخراج غاز ووقود عضوي مئه في المئه
صديق للبيئه
بدك تحضر وتوثق بالارقام شو هو مكونات
التخمير
[موسيقى]
اليوم ما بديتها اول مرحله من البروفوف
كونسب الا وهي عمليه التخمير والطحالب قصد
الاعداد لاستخراج الغاز والوقود في مرحله
ثانيه وقت الخبط واجهتنا مشكله صغيره اللي
هي انه ارتفاع الحموضه تعود المحتويات
فعشان هيك
يعلي الحموضه عشان يوصل لدرجه الحموضه
اللي هو بحاجه الى
كانت عمليه المراقبه من اشد العمليات
صعوبه خلال بعض الاحيان كانت تستلزم
المبيت الى جانب التجربه اللي اخذ عينات
متواصله طوال فتره العيد قصد النجاح هذه
العمليه في افضل الظروف
الفحوصات على العينه التي تحصلنا عليها
اليوم تضع انه الغاز الذي كان بحوزتنا غاز
قبل الاستيعاب
سي 2 سي 3 سي 1 مول
بالنسبه لحمدي قدر يثبت الفكره بتاعت
المشروع بتاعه
تعداد نفسي 100% معنويات ميه في المياه
التفاؤل مماثل
[موسيقى]
هذه كانت النتيجه بتاعتها اسابيع
هذا البوت وهذا الاوتبوت من هذا ما عنده
حتى قيمه لهذا عنده قيمه بغض النظر عن
لازم تكون عندها شروط معاينه اولا ثم شروط
تكون ملوثه للبيئه
انا ناشط بيئي او الواجب عندي باش نحمي
البيئه يعني طاقه هي ونوع اخر ملوث مثل
فحسب بس الطحالب الملوث البيئه معاها
تحالب اخرى
طريقه
فرزقه بطبيعه الحال
ولا فرزه بالجاذبيه
عشان تتخلص منها
في مكان بعيد مكان بعيد
انه موجود من الطحالب بدنا نعمل الغاز او
طاقه موجوده بانحاء كثيره السبب اللي خولك
او
خليك توصل لهالمرحله
انه طريقه التخبير هناك طريقه فيها ابداع
فيها شيء جديد مبتكر لالك
بس ما اشوف في معادله كيميائيه مش عشوائيه
هلا الحموضه قليله بزدهن شويه مياه ملح
هلا في شغله ثانيه يعني مش طابخه تبوله
يلا شوي من هون شوي من هون بدنا معادله
كيميائيه علميه وصلت لها ولا لا وصلت لها
القلب يخفق لكل مبدع عربي مشروع مملكه
التحكيم بعد قليل فاما يتوقف نبض قلب
جهازه عن الخفقان ام ان قلب زياد سياخ فك
فرحا بانجاز التاهل الى المرحله المقبله
خلونا نشوف تقريره
اشخاص المعرضين للجلطه القلبيه بعيشوا
حاله قلق دين والكابوس اللي بيعيشوا فيه
هو بسبب احتمال حدوث الجلطه باي وقت
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مين منا ما بتمنى انه يفيق من هالكابوس
ويعرف انه في طريقه بتمكنه من اكتشاف حصول
الجلطه القلبيه قبل الفواتير جهازي انا
بيبعث الامر فهو عباره عن اداه فعاله
لمراقبه القلب واكتشاف عوارض الجلطه
القلبيه بوقت كافي لمعالجتها
البرنامج تبعك بدنا نبرهن انه انت قدرت
تعطيني انذار مبكر قبل حادث القلب
هالانذار المذكر كل مكان ابكر كل ما انت
حلقت اكتر جهازي هو اداه بتكتشف تغيرات
هالشي بدل على تضيق بشرايين القلب اللي
ممكن يؤدي لحصول جلطه قلبيه
انا
قلت لهم
شهرين ثلاثه
صحيح ببينوا القلب تعبان انه الواحد راح
يصير معه هارت اتاك مع 30 دقيقه مثل ما هو
كان وعدنا
النقطه الثالثه بدنا نثبت هذه النتيجه لا
طبيب قلب وبن شهاده طبيب القلب
[موسيقى]
جهازي هو عباره عن جهاز لمراقبه القلب
واكتشاف حالات تضيق الشرايين وحالات حدوث
الجلطه القلبيه بوقت كاف يسمح بمعالجتها
وعدم التسبب في الوفاه احنا الناس اللي
عندهم القلب دول
على الجهاز ده ايه وتحطه فين وتشيله ازاي
بيعمل ايه طيب حاعطيكم مقاربه لحتى نفهم
الجهاز كيف بيشتغل اكثر الموجود بالسوق
هلا ما بعرف ان شاء الله متعوذ بس اذا حدا
منكم استخدم ما يسمى الهولتر هو عباره عن
جهاز بيحملوا المريض
بلزق الالكتوز على حاله بيحطوا بجيبه حجمه
هالقد تقريبا يقوم
يعني يقوم ريكورد لمده يوم او يومين يعيده
الى الطبيب الطبيب يقوم بالتحليل واكتشاف
ان كان هنالك عوارض او لا ما يميز هذا
الجهاز بانه لديه يعني فهو الحدود يعني
مثلا اس تي ريفي
على الفور يرسل الى المركز الخدمه يقومون
على الفور متخصصون بدراسه هذا الشيء اما
بيبعتوا له هل المساعده ان كان بحاجه
اليها شكرا رجعت لي قلبي
بلال
الدخان عمل على ابتكاره املا ان يرفعه الى
المرحله المقبله لكن هل سيتمكن من مواجهه
قوه الجاذبيه القاسيه للجنه التحكيم وكل
الصعوبات التي حاولت شده نزولا سنتابع
[موسيقى]
المشكله الاساسيه الموجوده هي ان الخلطات
الاسمنتيه تتعرض بشده للعوامل الجويه في
الارتفاع الشديد او الانخفاض او التبدل
المناخي اضافه الى ذلك ان الاسمنت بحد
ذاته ماده ناشره للحراره كل هذه العوامل
تؤدي الى اضعاف في الكتله الخرسانيه
الحل هو ايجاد مخطط بياني يربط بين
الحراره والزمن
سيتم التحكم باحرار الخرسان عن طريق
القالب حيث يزود القالب بشبكه من الانابيب
توضع في جدار القالب نستطيع امرار كميه
محدده من الماء بدرجه حراره معينه تنتقل
الحراره من الماء الى الخرسانه راح نزيد
تكييف حراره على هذا القالب ونصب فيه
الاسمنت نعمل فحص بنفس القالب بدون تكييف
حراره كمان
كان في كتير دقيقه لازم نكون منتبه لها من
ناحيه نعومه القالب من جوا وابعاد تكون
نظاميه حتى يقدروا يسحبوا باقي القطع على
نفس القطعه الاولانيه ممكن اطلع لعند
القالب بشتغل
وبالرغم من كل المساعدات اللي قدمنا له
اياها
بالامور اللي عم نعطيه اياها مشان هيك
تعذبنا معه
حطينا التجربه كانت بوقت متاخر بالليل
اضطريت تنام ليله كامله حتى اراقب الحراره
بما انه اول تجربه
[موسيقى]
واصل للنتيجه عن المعدل اللي بنوا معالج
بلال يعني حسب نظريته هو اللي كان بيحكيها
انه الجهاز تبعه النتيجه تبعه راح يعطينا
اكثر من الثاني يعتبر منيح
[موسيقى]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
مشروعي هو قوالب للتحكم بدرجه حراره
الخرسانه انا بالنسبه الي انت حققت يعني
بس عندي سؤال للمستقبل طيب اوكي تحكمت
بحراره الكونكريت مولد وحتحكمت بحراره
الكيوب اللي طلع طيب شو دخله بالانشاء ما
هو انت انت حققت درجه حراره حققت سترينك
في الكيوب خليته مختلف عن الواقع بالعكس
يعني ليش انا بدي اتحكم ليش بدي اخلي
السترينغ تبع
اليوتيوب هذا كيوب انا بتحكم فيه وبرميه
ما بستعمل للبنى انا حتى اثبت المبدا
العلمي طلب على مكعب صغير
طلب مني انا بالفعل انا مثبته على مكعبات
على قوالب كبيره انا عم بشتغل بالاساس على
قوالب كبيره وكنت مجهز حالي بس اجي على
التحكيم انه راح يصدموني بقالب كبيره كان
بالعكس طلبوا مني قالبه صغيره اذا كان
الامر اسهل الي نسبه نظريه على قوالب
صغيره
جهاز لتقييم اداء السائقين ستقيمه لجنه
التحكيم بعد قليل مقداد احمد من السودان
شاب نشيط مجتهد راح يدافع اكيد عن مشروع
امام اللجنه لكن بعدها التقرير
[موسيقى]
القياده غير الامنه تمثل خطر حقيقي على
الناس ويمكن لاي شخص ان يقع ضحيه بسبب
سائق متهور كثير من الشركات التي يوجد
لديها سيارات بتعاني والمشكله بسوء قياده
السائقين الموظفين لديها وهذا الشيء
بخليهم يلجاوا الى طرق غير فعاله
فكرتي انا هي الحل لهذه المشكله فهي عباره
عن جهاز مراقبه يستطيع من خلاله ان نعرف
سواء كان السائق يسوق بطريقه لائقه ام لا
ما رحنا لحوادث وانما نحن نعرضكم لخيالي
متهوره بدنا نشوف اذا هالبرنامج تبعك بقلب
الكمبيوتر بقلب السياره حلل وقلنا انه هون
في قياده متهور من اللي انت اخترت وين بدك
تحطهم بالسياره اول شيء هنفك العجل
الامامي ونركب السنسر الديسك بريك
ركبنا
وشويه السياره اوكي
[موسيقى]
مش كفايه محتاج كمان يعني جديد محتاج
جديده وبيغير الصفطي ولا بده يغير لا لا
لا لا حيتاخر
لانه هو تحت ضغط نفسي او خايف عم بيشوف
انه هو عنده كثير مشاكل عم يطلب قصص مش
عايزها
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم السلام
هو جهاز مراقبه اداء السائقين وتقييم اداء
السائقين انت جربت بعده
عشان تشوف الحاجات السائق بيعملها مختلف
عن السائق اخر ما هي او الفروق بينهما طيب
انا لا والله بصراحه يعني انا انا اتعاملت
مع سياره واحده حاليا وسائق واحد لا انا
انا
يعني
في بروفيشنال في
اعضاء لجنه التحكيم يقيمون اداء كل من سعد
حمدي زياد بلال ومقداد فمن سيتم استبعاده
يا ترى
من الدائره الساخنه الى منطقه الاستراحه
فاصل ونتابع امسيه اثبات الفكره في الموسم
الثالث من برنامج هجوم العلوم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا بكم مجددا مشاهدينا الكرام في
منافسه الموسم الثالث من نجوم العلوم 16
مبدع سيصبحون اليوم عشره تبقى دفعه اخيره
من المبدعين والبدايه مع حيدر الخزرجي من
العراق الذي ابتكره مكيفا صديقا للبيئه هل
سيتحمل هذا المكيف حراره جو المنافسه خاصه
حيدر الاول كان تغيير مناخ العراق
[موسيقى]
وشقد تمنينا لو الاجواء بالخارج مبرده مثل
ما هي مبرده بالداخل
وهذا ما اسعى الى تحقيقه من خلال اختراعي
نفس الشروط
نفس
الحراره مع الجهاز تبعك وبدون جهاز
تبعي
ضعيف
[موسيقى]
لان ما كانت كل السوائل وفق المواصفات
مبين هلا في فرق الهوى بس جربنا الجهاز
تبين انه فرق درجه الحراره عن الجو كان ما
بيتعدى من درجتين لخمس درجات بس فرق ست
درجات هذا اكثر شيء
قمت المشروع على اساس انه احصل من 20 الى
15 درجه مئويه فرق الحصول على ست درجات
مئويه يعني غير مرضيه بالنسبه الي عملنا
تجربه لوقت طويل هي عباره عن وضع الثلج
الجاف بمستوعب لحاله وضع ثلاث عينات من
سائل التبريد تعول حيدر بمستوعبات منفرده
وحطينا ثيرموميتر علشان نقيس الحراره
ويتبين عنا انه ثلج الجاف ضرب حافظ على
حرارته لمده اطول من السوائل الثاني اللي
عملها حيدر
اطمح لها انه نقل لمرحله الانجينيرغو ما
بعد الانجنيرنج وابدا مزازات ثقتي بنفسه
وانا مطمئن
[موسيقى]
سبب حراره الجو بفضاءات الخارجيه هو الشمس
كنا طلبنا محاضره من الدكتور
خبرنا انت شو عملت اسابيع الله يوفقك
صممت
جزئين الجزء الاول هو المظله المظله هي
حتحجب اشعه الشمس عن المستهلك
ولذلك حيصير فرق الدرجات الحراره وحتى
نتمتع بروده
الجهاز
يعني هذا هذا نموذج يتثبت على مظله اكبر
بس هذا
لمظله ممكن يعني اي شخص يحملها
الجهاز يتكون من
فان يحتوي
شوفوا المظله اذا بدك تفرجينا اياها في شي
بقلبها طبعا موجود نفس تركيب هذا الجهاز
بس على شكل اصغرتك بصب نحن بدنا نسكرها
ونشوفك
تفضل الجهاز يتكون من جزء رئيسيه الجزء
الاول هو قالب ينحط داخله السائل التبريد
بالنسبه للسائل التبريد هو محضر من ثلج
الجاف زائدا
استخدام الثلج الجاف اكثر من اسبوع انا
جدي كان في في الفلاحين
في الدوار كان في الصيف بتقعد الدنيا حر
وعنده ضيوف كان يجيبو لوح تلج يحط على
ترابيزه وبعدين جنبه هنا مروحه والمروحه
تبقى ايه الفرق ما بين ده والده درجه
البروده للسائل التبريد 75 تحت الصفر
ويطول لمده اسبوع طبعا كيلو جرام يطول مده
اسبوع في فرق كبير ما بين اللي هلا سمعناه
وما بين طموحك انه تغير طقس العراق اه
طبعا لان 100 غرام انا ما حسبت حساب
جو العراق او البصره
كم كيلو جرام بدي انت عده طرق حتى لطب جو
البصره يعني من وحده من الطرق انه هو
استخدم الجهاز حتى يبرد لي البحر او
الخليج اقدر ازيد البروده طبعا نسيم البحر
واقدر اخلي البصره
اسم الابتكار جهاز استشعار التوازن المائي
الاسم لوحده صعب فكيف حاله تطبيق لكن رؤوف
الطيلوني مجتهد ويعمل بلا كلل او ملل
خلونا نشوف كيف راح يواجه اللجنه بعد
التقرير
[موسيقى]
السابق في عمليات الحفر عن النفط وغيرها
من العمليات الهندسيه التي تحتاج الى
تحديد الزاويه كانت اجهزه الاستشعار
المستخدمه تتلف بسبب الحراره العاليه
والاهتزازات والظروف الصعبه فكرتي انا هي
جهاز استشعار يحدد الزاويه باعتماد على
حركه السائل داخل الكره وهو قادر على تحدي
كل الظروف الصعبه راح نحط سائل داخل كره
بقلب هذه الكره راح تحطوا حواس بتقدر
تترجم مستوى سائل الى اورينتيشن
المرحله الصناعيه كثير مهمه لانه على
اساسها راح نثقب الكره وهذا بياثر كثير
على دقه السنسور وحساسيته
[موسيقى]
بعد التقطيب حطينا داخل الكره سائل وهاي
الاسلاك هي بمثابه وشبكناهم على بحيث يقدر
يعطينا الزاويه
نعيدها اليوم كلش
مستحيل كان الوقت محصور عندي فحسيت انه
ممكن اني اكون الناس اللي طالعين من
هالمرحله طبعا عندي لك فكره مش عارف تحب
تعملها ولا لا
يا رب يا رب بس وقت
الحمد لله اشتغلت زي الفل
بده يتحمل درجات حراره عاليه بدنا نحطه
بدرجات الحراره اللي هي مناسبه لخواص
السائل
التحدي الاخير في هاي المرحله هو كاني اضع
هاي الكره داخل فرن على درجه حراره 100
مئويه او ستين مئوي وتتحمل وتضل شغاله
داخل هالبيئه
مشروع رؤوف مقبول روف اوف كونسبت
تبعه عم يعطينا وكمان بيقدر يتحمل حراره
عاليه
[موسيقى]
مشروعي هو جهاز استشعار التوازن بالاعتماد
على حركه السائل بالنسبه للجاذبيه الارضيه
من اهم مميزاته انه بيتحمل حاره بتصل ل
350 درجه مئويه على غير انه مبدا جديد
للجيروسكوب انت اللي عملته اذا الفتره
الماضيه لما نشوفك
بعدين
ساعدوك
هيثم ساعدك يعني هو مجموعه تبعاتكم هاي
السنه مش بس مبدعين
بس مش عارف هذا الجيل بيتميز كمان مش بس
بالابداع
انكون كولا بارت يعني مش كول يعني نايس
يعني مش عارف كيف احكي لك اياها
مش مشدودين على الموضوع يعني هيثم بساعدك
انت بتساعد واحد ثاني وشفت اكثر من مره في
الريبورت هذا الموضوع طبعا
كويس
يعني حتى عادتكم هيك ما شاء الله والله
بتفتح النفس لانه
[تصفيق]
حتى يعني مش مشدودين
راضيين بحكم الله يعني
وبنفس الوقت
مقاتلين يعني بسيطين بقيم بعالم اوروبا هو
احنا كل القدوه دائما
اوروبا ولكن هسه سبحان الله انقلبت موازين
اوروبا الان يقيموا على التيم مش على ورك
فهم لو كنت انت عالم ولا مبدع ما بيهمهم
بيهمهم انت كثير تتفاعل مع التيم ولا عندك
هذا شكرا
ابتكار الكويتي محمد الرفاعي راح يساعد
الكثير من ربات المنازل عبر الكي الالي
لجنه التحكيم راح تنظر في فعاليه هذا
الابتكار واثباتاته العلميه قبل ان تقرر
ان كانت مسيره محمد راح تستمر ام انه
سيبدا بكل ملابسه للعوده الى الوطن خلونا
نشوف
[موسيقى]
عمليه الكون عمليه متعبه وتاخذ وقت ولما
يبلش الواحد فيها يحس انه ما لها نهايه
وفعلا راح نرتاح ونوفر وقته جهد اذا حطينا
ملابسنا بالجهاز وخلينا الجهاز يسوي
المهمه بدلا منه قطعه صغيره فقط انت عم
تبرهن انه انا فيني مرق البخار عليها من
خلال الكمبيوتر انا حاط لي هدف انطلاق
تكون من هالبرنامج
في بدايه التصنيع اكتشفنا ان الديزاين هذا
عمليا ما نقدر نطبقه بالموارد الموجوده
حاليا فاضطرينا نغير الديزاين بيوم واحد
خلينا نقول
عنا فاضي بنكون حطينا الموت نفس الحركه
هنا ومع ذلك في مشاكل جدا كبيره ومن اولها
طبعا الجهاز كان شكلها الحمد لله حلو يعني
يوم تركب بس مع الاسف يعني اداء ما كان
نفس شكله يعني مش فيه الحين
المشكله الكبيره بالنسبه لي ان المحرك
اللي عندي هو ما تتحمل الوزن الجهاز
بصراحه انا حاسس بغموض شوي وتخوف قليل
[موسيقى]
زملاء معاي بصراحه ما قصروا وغيرت
الديزاين من حرف الاتش الى حرف التي وهذا
التغيير ادى الى ان يقل وادى الى ان
الموتر يقدر يتحمل وزن زياده والحمد لله
ضبطت معي الطريقه وقدر انه يتحكم بالجهاز
اذا تاهلت باذن الله في مفاجات
[موسيقى]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم طبعا
فكره الجهاز
الاختراع عباره عن جهاز قوي اوتوماتيكي
مشكلة شوي
طبيعي طبعا البروتيت لازم يكون شكل كبير
وبعدين انا كنت مسويه على حرف اتش
وواجهتنا مشاكل بحرف الاتش فلقيت حل الحمد
لله اني احوله حرف تيم مثل ما انتم شايفين
وراح استغني عن الطرف هذا وبالطريقه هذه
راح يصغر الجهاز بشكل كبير
لو بالحجم ده لازم لازم ما يدخلش اي بيت
يعني لازم تعمله وبعدين تبني البيت حواليه
لا بس انت لا يغرك ترى هو هذا بشكل كبير
المراحل الجايه راح تشوف الفرق
[تصفيق]
اعضاء لجنه التحكيم يقيمون اداء حيدر رؤوف
ومحمد ونتيجه النهائيه راح نعرفها بعد
لحظات
16 مبدع مره وامام لجنه التحكيم الكل قال
كلمته والفرص امام الجميع كانت متساويه
ولكن للاسف قوانين المسابقه لن تسمح بمرور
اكثر من عشره مبدعين الى المرحله التاليه
وهي مرحله الهندسه عشره على عشره المبدعين
16 اكيد دائره الخطر تطار الجميع ونتائج
اصبحت حاضره ساخنه جدا كانت هذه المنافسه
وراح نبدا
بالنتائج
[موسيقى]
بالمركز الاول
هو هيثم دسوقي من مصر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
بمركز الثاني
مشترك الثاني هو محمد زياد الشعري من تونس
[تصفيق]
المشترك الثالث وبرصيد نقطه واحده فقط عن
محمد زياد الشعري من تونس الذي حل بالمركز
الثالث هو
[موسيقى]
او هي سيرين الشراري من الاردن
[تصفيق]
حصل عليه نواف سعيد بن البحرين
خامس كان محجوز للشخص
[موسيقى]
هو حمدي حشاد من تونس
[تصفيق]
اللي حصل على مركز السادس هو
عبد الله رويشد من السعوديه
مركز السابع كان محجوز لي محمد الرفاعي من
الكويت
المركز الثامن كان محجوز لي السوداني
مقداد احمد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
المركز التاسع كان محجوز
لزياد سنكري من لبنان برصيد 79.5
[تصفيق]
باقي موقع واحد مكان واحد متسابق واحد
متشارك واحد
راح يحجز مكانه ايضا الى مرحله الهندسه
فيها الرحله هذه الطويله اللي امتدت على
مدى ثلاث اسابيع
وائل
دبابيدي
سعد رؤوف اللي حصد المركز الاخير
وصل الى مرحله الهندسه برصيد 78.8 هو
[موسيقى]
مرحله الهندسه تبدا الان المشاريع تاخذ
اشكالها ولا مجال للخطا
مرحله هي في قلب منافسات نجوم العلوم
ومسارها سيحدد بشكل كبير مستقبل المشاريع
المشاركه
لحظات من التعب والفرح من الخيبه والامل
من الاستسلام والاصرار
تابعوا معنا مرحله الهندسه في الموسم
الثالث من نجوم العلوم
[موسيقى]